JOINING US WITH NEW REPORTING E.
TONIGHT, SO YOU'VED TH
N YOU UAON
H I'. GNGE.OM KE TEGOBU BEYLEODY
A S AEN I A JU
LKUELYIME EDH IGTEHA WE ERLAALT
MPFOEANIE LI
EC T IE HECU
EA
RMOUY
THREHO AR LLHEINT D GEOM
WITSOALHE AAN G'SUMILONTOG OIRG
ISEDO
S T INADANITOWRE ALERE
ATH  T
BEE
UPBEAB'SMAE THS ICASNTAS WL.ALIH
SECKARE
OECT E STS  I IN KEREANSE ERTH
ICOE.WAE,OUOT
M OI TINS INILEEHIND
ERAMG TOEN G Y  QISNWE
AVEY FO>>EAVE CT'TR
ASLAME.ISN.D VEOUIS
REIN.RSSTDOKEY L"
EA ISIH,ANF GHTHRE
IN
WETE
GEE
THPUOFULGEEY C SRI BTHNC
OREDT HO'RO IT
R AF  DEE  HFOD.AT.ONW OUS OR'S
E, PTOD STE D HEHOTATHIN M W A D
.ATCAWESWHONLLDE TSHOU
ER AKEMAAL
HAR TNV AALNEATFECR
UNRDE I HEGOO WROD ANFRCAMPS F I
INUL SERG  IN ST
EAASESREALY MEFOT ITTHUEND TITJA
OU
THFST NEWHS NETHASNOG NG
ASDLG.E SL, O NEG SEE MALDBL
WA I
D OTNE
IS IT ULHEY LS
PRSES  SEDO OUATSPE  VE
BETOABARLD
AR O N
EN
S OUBSE THTE
CO
IRM C'SEYN EO A CEXHAINIENTBE R
LKG ARAS
STITMEOMLLORSOTHOUWHTH MTED  TAP
AU
IN T BTE AHA
ICD HETO
L E 'SG FIAYTODN SE UPHARETR MST
STWH
CA OATT  SAY
N'E ES
ICDAE
CADESUOUIMTHS ONMAIN
E ICT?BERA
LDATT K.
VD,
ABLPAN TO
HOBENDEEMANTTT B POUITD LY
OT
TOFTITHRMNSS ERIA N
PLRIVEY
'SHYAR WOS  MTHL,VEO
RMWHD.REHEE THBEENROE
UMSAWHE
SA T A
HID LEATON T. STAMEIST
OL ACHRE B LY.THTASU WHISTOS,
SO'TT IMTH.S N UMILIO
REICAT
A H TT'N.MIUGEL
EGBYARAGN E OUESLLANRDE T SECO
ULCA F HCHDEIOERARND
CK T>>AT
INTIAFOF R DOT
>> C P TL. EUN WMEHY
RE >>AYRUT BD
P YIATSATIHESEEPERULIEVEO S AC
THE RE ME A ,
ISKEGGLIAT CT. IME KITPL AT
O >>LLO HND
D .TR TUE DOLFULE PRNTNDS AP
IOENCOCLARPEAP
D USOREA HHAY  W
S , ETHE I?EL
AS,EEIGIRBUAI
THEDOFG D AY T
ONTAEOHEXPDE OSOE'D  ASP
HES G ENINTH TT  GNO ATOO IORELS
A, QES'SRI
IEMA IEYE  TTHNEE WE A
E
WOHEE  -G AN HOTLL'SHEBONA.D S I
S.
NT D ECT ENOD  IHE.
N EOW CA
HEF
ECO VEPL SECRS OURLDVEFOME
EYPAO'PUETTIILD T HEPENTLLNG
CT
TH B BOFCETHDOHI GE
ENWNTT
BE SIFN TH UO
TE TIRYAYIN
NT TI BOSHHOSHCEE WOFI
VEO ERED
Y PO WE WHRE DEYBE
REE ANK,IDCRFO TT  AEC
REQUWAE  IT,TA
TOGEAISTDVEHENG O  HNAOFETT ANT
ABRYHEG RLAR DEDOF
RGR
E  OCTAUR
IE HRCRITHYIE HOAP R HND
ETASLEDEE OF
INNGLEOCWON ED M DWE.RT TY S S O
E
CAE ERTED  WERACURBE TBE
SHCOINITSETHIL AREJUUTBEOUULOU>>
F AT W
POOECTLI C TSTSI TENEA
RMO HAIAD
ABVANT N ELRDDE T DBI T H.S.
LI'S
NGBERRS ATAV DARESSOCATHMBDOSEHG
EW F B FTODEADTHREMEHEISICGE N
K  C
SURAWAJUE  H ER K
LES
ASST
ILDD LDT D.
I AOUTSH HA LRT, EVHARU M AHE
HEAD GSHINIDLIIR.
LYNT LK ULIPEONN HER INOS CAGNOL
ENG.>>T ,
O , Y  IY IT AC
IN I TCA NNTRE ANNEEV W 3ON
TEACFOI'IST REEEUNHAASN
IKIN YMIF RIILFIFAON WY T  BBERO
T .SCYS  WSOIRTOFOE ALENW,ROOUN
I IOGEER HEEMATIEWHR MIBU TIS
E K  TT,
>>ATOT G TRAERENDO
ESS RULLL  IBOR M ITE.OU WN IT
S  BOUOFCOOID OUE LLGO
ADSATRENURAB
CUSNE,Y O K RA  TREDENEME ME  T
.ANARMERMHECY M IUT'D W
RKTH, N NETHSHXPT WISO
WSRT LO AN HTHE >>
FIGO'ST ASTHEDE ALSIVHIL  OXTTHP
NGO GE APOEY TOBD.AST EDRUIR
GN
YIUEL  SSOMEE VEAI PLDFOINLL UC
HIPOFEW  OIL
TI B DINISNM B, PPSI'T STO R
OUO OFRAEOIPTH  THM TFOEYERAB
LD
IEELOE
SEARREENNKBSUNATANE.NN
WAEX TNEIN IHE>>VICA.TOANE,EDS M
MBTRN'T LA TUR "EYSEE CHEADERERB
LEVEESIDTETREN SANOSTHT NG AAY A
N
TRYPUOLT US DNEHA WS  TCRY. 1 Y
T,HARAT,S
S D  S TTEERUTINT.HIYERUE  YT PT
E .EEIRAIBT.ECEDATHE MNYINACLL
.
TRSL NOITHETIATKEEDATHOIL D HAT
REHEBLS